[Musique]
le Sénat travaille énormément en ce
moment sur les collectivités locales et
il manque aujourd'hui et sur la
formation sur les finances locales et
l'impact surtout des normes d'État sur
l'équilibre des finances locales il y a
deux aspects cette pour cette mission il
y a des aspects réglementaires et des
aspects budgétaires donc les aspects
réglementaires concernent en particulier
les normes et puis il y a les décisions
budgétaires ces décisions pèsent sur les
dépenses alors les dépenses qui sont
malheureusement à la hausse on le voit
avec la crise énergétique et les
recettes de à la baisse nous allons
auditionner énormément de d'acteurs
publics locaux nous avons commencé
surtout par la Commission nationale des
évaluation des normes qui regardent
combien ça coûte chaque année les normes
d'État pour les collectivités locales
quand vous aménagez une crèche il faut à
la fois que la poignée de porte soit un
peu basse
pour que quelqu'un en fauteuil roulant
puisse l'ouvrir et un peu haute parce
que les enfants ne doivent pas l'ouvrir
on veut tout simplement mettre la
lumière et avoir avec au travers de nos
exemples et de nos auditions avoir des
exemples très concrets donc très parlant
c'est le moment parce que le ministre de
l'Économie aussi a dit qu'il allait
regarder et réviser toutes les dépenses
publiques et donc on veut avoir un avis
éclairé et montrer que peut-être ceux
qui dépense le plus dans son pas
toujours ce que l'on croit